one dnc committee member even told the
times quote to say our country was on
the right track would flagrantly depart
from reality so naturally biden knows
just who to blame anyone but himself and
according to the washington post joe was
lashing out at his own staff even his
chief of staff ron claim now biden also
frequently is blaming florida senator
rick scott for some reason according to
joe rick scott is responsible for all of
our economic woes he's one senator it's
not a joke as he likes to say not a joke
uh for god's sakes it's rick scott's
fault anyway now senator scott is
responding in a strong way take a look
joe biden has destroyed america's
economy it's time to be honest with the
american people joe biden is unfit for
office and should resign
senator rick scott wisconsin
i think the man has a problem i'm rick
scott from florida and i do have a
problem and so does every american
biden is forcing america into a
recession i've got a plan to turn our
country around take a look at
rescueamerica.com i approve this message
all right here now with reaction florida
senator rick scott i'm not sure why you
take up so much space in his head but
apparently you do he mentioned your name
frequently which i guess is a
a compliment
so he really has destroyed the economy
41-year high of inflation you see the
numbers uh definite recession on the
horizon according to the experts even
lawrence summers um and you want him to
resign but we both know he's never going
to resign so what's the next best thing
we can do
well first off let's let's here's the
problem joe biden has one he was a rich
kid they say oh he's average joe no he
went to an expensive prep school and
then he's been on the public you know
dole for 50 years we've been paying his
way for 50 years he has no idea about
anything and he doesn't care and so he
has no plan to fix anything he's
confused he's incapacitated he's unfit
for office if i was in my business life
here's why i'd go to joe i say joe nice
guy nice try you got to leave you cannot
do the job so we've got we've got to
make sure we win in november and joe
we've got to stop the bite
administration from doing all these
things five dollar gas i mean
gas impacts families i grew up in a poor
family i mean my mom would be struggling
like crazy right now to put food on the
table to feed five kids and put gas in
the car to get to work that's going on
all across this country right down all
across my state so we've got to change
we've got to become energy independent
we cannot keep doing what biden's doing
we've got to fix the supply chain but
you know what look at who's look at who
biden picks i mean buddha judge armando
they have no idea how to do anything
they've never done anything so that the
whole lot of them ought to resign let's
start all over you know i'm looking at
the the amount of pressure look the
definition of insanity is what i said it
is you try the same thing over and over
again it doesn't work the question is he
sees what's happening with the high
price of gas it's we're setting one
record after another he reads the papers
somebody's got to be telling them it's a
41-year high of inflation and this is
not transitory as he first said
so the question is
why is there this reluctance and
resistance on the part of biden and the
democratic party you know why are they
okay with importing oil rather than
producing it right here at home because
to me mother earth is better off if we
produce it
yeah and
who doesn't want to be independent we
all did when we left home we wanted to
be independent our country should be
independent we shouldn't be dependent on
anybody else for anything and maybe our
allies but nobody else so i think it's
as simple as this he doesn't understand
it he doesn't understand the economy and
he doesn't care because he's never had
to he's never had a tough financial day
in his life he doesn't know what it's
like to be poor he's never been poor
he's always been taken care of he's
always gotten a paycheck because you the
taxpayer paid for it i mean and look at
who's around him there's nobody around
him that's ever done anything in
business it's a whole bunch of
government people that think government
can run everything these people have no
concept of how you fix the supply chain
let me ask you this
you're in the senate you deal with these
democrats is that they're not i know joe
manchin is probably on our side on this
maybe christian cinema i don't know are
there any other democrats that are
looking at the high price of gasoline
record high inflation and saying rick
can we work together to get the economy
back in better shape
and maybe that includes
restarting the keystone xl pipeline
according to the premier in alberta we
be getting in 900 000 barrels of
canadian oil a day by now had we
finished that is there anybody there
that you're talking to on the democratic
side that is willing to break ranks and
and give some financial relief to
everyday americans
no i mean they'll they'll go say they
care about now they're up for election
they see how bad their poll numbers are
so they'll go say they care about it but
will they go vote for it will they
propose anything to do it there's
nothing that comes out the democrats
that fixes anything with regard to
supply chain gas prices you know energy
independence any of these things baby
formula i mean they don't they have
nothing they have no plan to fix
anything booty just came and testified
he's been out the port in long beach one
time since he's been in office i asked
him what are you doing to fix the supply
chain well not my problem raimondo
secretary commerce she says i says what
are you doing about inflation that's the
federal reserve's responsibility they
take no responsibility and starts with
biden he takes no responsibility
complete blame everybody else he's not
responsible for anything that's what the
democrats are doing right senator rick
scott thank you we appreciate you being
with us hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else